[تصفيق]
لم يحدث المد الاحمر الذي توعد به
الجمهوريون باتجاه الانتخابات النصفيه الى
وضع متارجح لا يمنح انتصارا صريحا للحزب
الجمهوري فان احد اكثر الانماط ثباتا في
التاريخ السياسي الامريكي في الطريق لان
يكسر وهي خساره حزب الرئيس بعد سنتين من
توله منصبه اعتاد الناخبون الامريكيون
اتخاذ هذا الموعد الانتخابي فرصه للتصويت
في ما يشبه الاستفتاء على شعبيه الرئيس
فبعد عامين على وصول الديمقراطي باراك
اوباما الى البيت الابيض عام 2008 خسر
الديمقراطيون 63 مقعدا في مجلس النواب
خلال انتخابات التجديد النصفي عام 2010
وعلى نحو مماثل ومعهود خسر الحزب الجمهوري
واحدا واربعين مقعدا في مجلس النواب عام
2018 اي بعد سنتين من انتخاب دونالد ترامب
رئيسا للبلاد
وعلى امتداري تاريخ الانتخابات في
الولايات المتحده منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه عام
1945 الى اليوم خسر حزب الرئيس في 17
موعدا للانتخابات النصفيه التي تجرى في
منتصف الولايه الرئاسيه من اجمالي 19
موعدا انتخابيه كانت تصويت في جل
الانتخابات اجراء عقابيا يقره الناخب
الامريكي في حق الرئيس
عاده ما تتدنان نسب شعبيه الرؤساء في
منتصف ولاياتهم الرئاسيه فاذا كانت نسبه
شعبيه بعيدا حاليا في حدود الاربعين في
المئه فان النسب المماثله حصل عليها سلف
هدونالد ترامب عام 2018 وبارك اوباما عام
2010 وقبلهما بالكليتون عام
بات الطريق سالكا الى كسر القاعده محاطه
بعوامل مؤثره على خيارات الناخب جرت
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه هذه السنه
فالمناخ السياسي استثنائيون الى حد كبير
في ظل مخاوف على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
لاسيما وان ميول بعض المرشحين الجمهوريين
واضحه نحو التطرف الى اقصى اليمين يضاف
الى ذلك قضايا اجتماعيه ملحه تشغل المواطن
الامريكي وعلى راسها الحق في الاجهاض الذي
ابتله قرار للمحكمه العليا شهر يونيو
الماضي ويبدي الحزب الديمقراطي نزوعا نحو
السعاده